it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all that exclusive low discounts to
start shopping you can scan the QR code
on your screen right now or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle host Gail bass
joins us right now good morning Gail
good morning
now this is you know on the brink of a
new year new year new year for me I want
a new way new waistline and you know
you need to start exercising and guess
what these Ray J speakers these speakers
by raycon from Ray J they're fantastic
we have the everyday speakers but check
out this one this is the fitness speaker
it has a strap on it so you can carry it
with you okay it has fantastic sound
listen to this oh I'll prove it because
I love a good french horn okay
where we at talk to me now hold up wait
a minute
the quality that's high quality and he's
gotten awards for these the quality of
these
and what's wonderful about them is you
compare them together and you could have
up to 21 hours of sound if you have the
volume at like 50 so if you're having a
party where you know you've done your
exercise but your friends are coming
over and to the backyard you can have up
to 21 hours of music with this so that's
fantastic okay so what's the price point
oh the price point is great because we
have these for 29 24.99 to 99.99 this is
the power Boombox you want to get that
too remember the old blue boxes of the
day you can walk around oh yeah if you
wanna if you wanna no need to take a CD
just connect it to your phone Raheem
action I like this oh yeah you got it
you got it all right so what do we have
right here uh I love this for our CBS
deals because you have a lot of people
living in apartments me I have a shared
driveway with my neighbor and I have to
worry about like wild animals coming to
eat my plants and so this will give me a
little notice of somebody or something
is in the driveway it won't surprise you
it has 10 to 20 second delay this is
from luminology this is just a dual
action motion light so it's just yeah
right there and it has like 1 000 lumens
so it's going to really brighten it up
and look how easy the outdoors yes it is
waterproof too so you don't have to
worry about that and it has a bracket so
it's easily attachable if you could set
up your Christmas tree put that in a
bracket you could do this put it indoors
and apartment complexes for those dark
hallways yes how much is this
37.99 it's 35 off and it's fantastic
it's a great cost for some security
absolutely this is the mobility wall I
love this because you always get that
one knot in your back either if you're
sitting a lot you're standing a lot or
there's just a space that you want to
work you get this Mobility wall it's a
bracket you put between the doorways at
your home and there you see me
demonstrating it and it's a foam roller
so I'm I'm rubbing my back there but you
can also make it lower so you can rub
that inner thigh you know because you're
an athlete you know you get that little
sore spot there you can work that or
underneath your arm you could just put
it to the level you want and also you
can move it up in the doorway so you
don't have to remove it all the time it
stores up stores up there you can still
close the door that is great what's the
price on this the price on this is 77.99
it is 35 off I love that what about this
this is what you were using earlier yeah
this is the neck I love the Necco
because it's a strong shiatsu massager
and though I had it on my neck I use a
lot on my lower back my lower back
because my lower back really always gets
to me when I hike a lot so this is
something that people would really love
we have it for so it's a legit massages
it is it's strong it's powerful and heat
and and it does have heat that's what
makes it spectacular the price on this
is 119 but if you bundle that with this
this is our air c pro you know I was
staring at that yeah I know exactly you
need this and somebody who now sits at a
desk and your son who's now playing
balls he's gonna
he's gonna compression it puts on your
legs it's fantastic I love it it's like
getting a firm hug especially if you
have like a little sore spot you want to
work out I see these at NFL facilities
all of the time absolutely if you bundle
these together it's 269. only on
cbsdeals.com you want to get in now oh
that's a great price yeah oh this is
awesome go best you're the best I
appreciate it well thank you all right
of course we partnered with all of these
companies to get these deals you can buy
anything that you saw and more scan the
QR code on your screen right now or head
over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now we
will be right back